Citadel is fantastic I love the show now
you and your co-star are like two of the
best looking people who are like super
even though it's not a superhero then
you guys can [__] kill anybody shoot
anybody I love it I think you play it
perfectly why are you doing your own
stunts because I'm good at them first of
all yeah okay I started my training or
like everything I've learned has been on
the job I didn't go to film school I
started when I was very young and back
in the day in like Bollywood movies when
like stunts were being performed like we
didn't even have a female stunt guy
sometimes it was a little man in a wig
his arms shaved like running to be me or
whatever and I was like or riding a
horse because you didn't have a stunt
guys so I over time just so that my
character would look more convincing
kind of learned how to do it myself so
that my face would be on camera so it
didn't feel like an obvious like cut
distant person what does that entail
when you say you do your own in other
words did you like I see that Keanu
Reeves I've seen film of him where he is
handling actual guns and goes to a gun
range and he can draw shoot really do it
convincingly like a real expert you're
saying that you went and trained with
guns and trained that that specifically
yes we had to do weapons training combat
training learn how to be comfortable
with knives guns I hate guns and weapons
but she's
extremely equipped to be able to get out
of very tricky situations and that is
literally her job my character so I had
to be convincing enough and a big
mandate from the russos came that they
were like listen the Russo Brothers the
Russo Brothers yes the producer Brothers
Joe and Anthony they're the executive
producers of the season of Citadel and
you know they're very closely creatively
involved and they said that
you know your your characters are not
superheroes this is not a Marvel
Universe you're not gonna wear whatever
your helmet on and then it can be a
stunt person it's like it has to we want
to be able to see your characters bleed
the viewer has to feel a visceral
reaction when your characters go through
what they go through and as a female who
was anyway I felt a little bit
not pressured I would say but like I
really wanted to show up for my
character because the Spy genre you know
just has like the Monopoly has been guys
like the the spies of the guys so here
was my character and I wanted to show up
for her